remember Ron Howard he used to be an
actor he became famous playing Opie
Taylor on the Andy Griffin show then
Richie Cunningham on happy days before
he moved behind the camera the
oscar-winning directors new project is a
documentary released by CBS Films the
untold story of legendary tenor Luciano
Pavarotti in this clip from Pavarotti
his fellow opera star Placido Domingo
tells us what it's like singing with him
[Music]
at the moment of being on the stage
there was the competition okay like
anything you will do I can do better
[Music]
Ron Howard joins us at the table Ron
good morning you've done by my count
three documentaries now about musicians
and music yes
you don't sing though do you not not so
you'd want to hear it so what attracted
you to this one characters it's it's
always about the characters you know the
first one was a jay-z and and and this
festival that he was curating and it was
a fascinating collection of characters
and I found the story inspiring Beatles
eight days a week this is the same
creative team that worked on that
documentary which I directed well that
was about this collective this this sort
of Band of Brothers going on this
adventure and here's this unbelievably
charismatic individual this is a story
of a whole life he's funny
he's a genius and his life isn't
opportunity run the more I watch this
movie I thought this could be just an
opera and itself and the film is
structured like an hour well I when I
started actually pursuing and I think
what really convinced me that I wanted
to make it as a movie I want to create a
theatrical experience it's actually
combining his charisma and personality
and the power of those close-ups I mean
a director I'm watching him singing
these Arya's and I'm saying this is like
this is like Brando you know I deliver
and this is unbelievable then I went and
read the lyrics to those are is those
songs and I felt like wait a minute he's
telling his story yeah he's singing you
weren't enough of him going in where I'm
not particular always admired it
respected it but I mean it's not again
the music's a great opportunity though
yes for for people who do love it or are
just discovering it and we made sure the
sound is the sound is amazing but one
thing that really struck me about this
is this is it's an epic life and you got
both his his wife and his lovers to
speak to you how difficult was that well
I think that says something about about
Luciano I mean you know he he he was
incredibly romantic and and
so that's not a euphemism for being
player he had these deep loves and and
he loved life and everybody around him
whether they had a romantic connection
whether they were family whether they
were colleagues they it's you know you
can just tell in all the interviews
despite the hurt they still felt the
love like absolutely and at the end of
his life they said the fact that you had
his ex-wife
yes that's what struck me too and his
current wife and a couple of ex-lovers
talking about I was blown away by that
but I was also blown away by him as a
person he said I'm basically never happy
right I'm always searching for something
what was it about him in particular that
stood out you I was very touched by this
man well he his story is very emotional
yeah and and of course that always
appeals to me you know in a character
story you know Brian Grazer and I had
imagined I've done a lot of movies based
on real events and and so it's been
interesting to move into the documentary
world but his he is so charismatic
and yet he has those insecurities he has
a vulnerability so yes he's a genius
what he does is unbelievable it's almost
athletic it's like a feat breathe that
we're going to say it really is like
athlete but he's relatable you know so
this is this really powerful combination
and I think that's one of the things
that makes the story as sick as a kid
yeah and that really affected his
outlook on a life that's what he said
that he had a near-death experience as a
child which we go into in in in the
documentary and by the way he he tells a
lot of the his own story we were able to
find so many great interview footages
amazed I'm his family yeah shared this
this you know where he's very it's raw
and it's vulnerable and it's and it's
real so we felt like this is a chance to
tell a complete story doesn't matter
whether you know anything about him or
opera yeah and yet use that music to
help build the emotion and and and also
the other thing that he cared about was
bringing democratizing opera and I
thought well using his story and opera
to make a movie is is hopefully
extending that agenda and you've got to
really see it on a big screen to fully
appreciate it I think I was about yeah
with the big speakers I know you're open
days are over people in the studio
yesterday
shall remain nameless John we're singing
the theme song where does Opie sit with
you today you ever think about him I
well he he comes up almost every day and
my wife Cheryl has taken to watching the
show again two people it's never been
off the air since 1960 because I've been
able to accomplish my dreams of really
not being a director of being a
storyteller work collaborating with so
many amazing people at such a high level
you know that's that's a part of my life
that I really cherish yeah people bring
it up now it just makes me smile when I
felt like don't you know but I think
I've been able to kind of grow that and
just appreciate yeah it was wonderful
watching you it still is Ron Howard it's
great to have you at the table I love
love love Pavarotti and you are best to
Cheryl thank you